au ras du sol fabien bourgeois essayer
de retrouver les quelques plants de
betteraves sucrières ayant survécu aux
gelées dans cette parcelle
particulièrement exposés les pertes sont
massives
les températures relevées ont été de
l'ordre de - 7 - 6 - 7 - 8 et donc on
constate que il ya 100% l'intégralité
des smic ont été bons étaient gelés quoi
pour ce planteur la seule solution est
donc de ressemer l'intégralité de ses 20
hectares de betteraves en espérant qu'un
nouvel aléa ne viennent pas annihiler ce
surplus de travail chez cet autre
exploitant de la beauce l'inquiétude est
réelle
après les lourdes pertes de 2020 liés à
la vie rose de la betterave cyprien
thierry avait utilisé en mars des
semences enrobées de néonicotinoïdes
pour prévenir un éventuel retour de la
jaunisse pour ces deuxièmes semaille il
n'y a plus droit et le résultat devient
incertain pour le deuxième se mit donc
ces graines là ne sont pas traitées donc
on est incertain on ne sait pas la
jaunisse c'est à dire c'est des pucerons
qui vont piquer la betterave
donc on
on attend de voir ces puits seront
aujourd'hui on les voit pas et à
surveiller dc dc d'ici quinze jours
trois semaines quand la betterave sera
sorti de terre et les dégâts sur la
betterave sucrière ne sont pas les seuls
soucis des agriculteurs de la beauce de
probable baisse de rendement sur
plusieurs céréales blé orge colza
pourraient encore alourdir le bilan des
gelées